so leonardo dicaprio obviously
incredible actor
agreed
incredible actor but probably even
better at being a bachelor
right like bachelor of uh
the highest proportion perpetual
bachelor and um
i don't know if you know this but
obviously he dates young hot women and
typically
once they turn age 25
he cuts them off that's happened more
than once oh we're going to go through
the dating list of leonardo dicaprio
right here
so
he's dating a current girl called
camilla marone you know what she looks
like you know who she is no basically he
treats women like milk they if they have
an expiration date of 25
time for a new thing of milk
yes horrible all right maybe so
she's 25 and let's pull up a picture of
her i don't know if we can show this on
the screen
so they've been together for four years
she turns 25 in the next few months
okay so the prediction is that she's
about to go i don't know these are what
the rumors are this is what we're gonna
speculate on and then we can go over his
dating history as well he's dated
leonardo dicaprio by the way how old do
you think leonardo dicaprio is
46. 46.
uh he's 47 now oh
he's 47 not bad
um by the way i think he's kind of like
the man i mean he's the modern george
clooney in my opinion um
so who has he dated there's a picture of
him with gizelle tom brady's wife all
right
uh well when he dated her he dated paris
hilton
barr rafaeli israeli supermodel oh god
right yes um he dated blake lively
before ryan reynolds and he actually
dated a girl who lived in miami for a
long time i'm friends with nina agdal
she actually dated my boy patrick and my
boy reed
that anyway we've hung out uh many times
with leo you've had no well i have hung
out with leo in miami but
i'm saying the nina whatever so
this is his dating history we'll go
through this but now there's basically
there's rumors
keep scrolling down eric can people see
this on screen
yes okay so so we'll you know we'll kind
of go there now there's rumors that
basically he's back to
partying with his boys a little bit more
than spending time with this girl camila
marone we'll go real fast he dated demi
moore
just keep going we'll go as soon as you
recognize somebody we'll just keep keep
going keep going keep going keep going
all right paris hilton he dated for a
little while boom giselle back in the
day there's bar rafaeli gorgeous you're
going to notice a similar theme here
with the ladies they're all kind of
blondish kind of gorgeous well not kind
of all gorgeous
um
yeah i got it similar theme we got going
on here right amber got a chance
yeah david uh this is
eerily similar to my dating list
yes david dated half these girls now
this girl uh back up this girl is a
brunette uh-oh lorena ray look at that
smoke show by the way keep going
okay and now this is his current
lady friend scroll up a little bit that
make sure that's her name yes camila
marone okay so um
long story short
uh he dates beautiful women
even longer story short
once they turn 25 he tends to kind of
move on so allegedly there's rumors that
who knows what's going on he's spending
out time
so
long story short again how do you feel
about leo the age gap 47
24 25
uh any initial thoughts before we get
into kind of the dialogue here your eyes
just fluttered so let's start with you
amber
just endless male privilege
this is male privilege yeah i mean you
guys don't have a biological clock you
have nothing that tells you when you
need to do something at any phase of
life you can make babies until you're
dead
so of course of course you want to date
younger why no man has ever said i'm too
old for you
a guy goes am i too old for you okay
right valid point actually that happened
to me recently
again 40 i was
with a girl recently this is a few
months ago and
i was like look we should hang out
another time because we were and she
goes she was actually british she goes
i really like you but i just i you're a
little old for me that was the first
time a girl has ever said that
and she's 25 i'm like a little old for
you we're in freaking miami what are you
talking about right here like this is
nonsense my my ex-girlfriend was a year
younger than you what are you talking
about here and for the first time i was
like damn
i'm old yeah you're just getting into a
different category i true i do need to
you know because a 25 year old probably
i mean maybe she's assuming you're
looking maybe at 40 maybe you want to
settle down and have a family i do i do
right and that is probably the exact
reason why you didn't text that girl at
40.
well yes because i was like yeah because
you're maybe not ready to or maybe you
don't want that future she focused on
business good for her yes um but you're
looking ahead to her now as not a
potential wife because you want to have
kids and that's kind of an advantage you
say business good for her she did she's
actually a doctor yeah
well
she's a phd i don't know if she's like
an md but
a doctor i don't know
i don't know if good for her okay
because
you know society tells these women to
get an education go to work get a job
real great now she's 40 and she's not
married no kids
did she feel happy she looked very happy
so
i don't know how long she's going to be
happy for next thing you know she's 44
years old
unmarried no kids i don't know if that's
the look for a an attractive woman it
depends on what you want out of life i
look for an attractive i'm just saying
you mean an attractive partner not an
attractive woman because she was
attractive you said she left yes i'm
just yes yes she looked great um
but i don't know if that's the best that
matters
because eventually
eventually um
the goal in my opinion is to settle down
at some point or who just in general for
that's not that can't be a general goal
that's your goal okay well we're talking
goals here not everybody has to have
kids well here's the question
let's get jenny's opinion here um
what's the line meaning leo's 47. this
girl is 24.
in your mind like have you ever dated a
guy much older than you yes you have
what was that age gap
um 16 years 16 years
yeah that was exactly what my
ex-girlfriend was 16 years and how'd
that work out it didn't well it lasted
i'm still singing
why did it not work but going back to
the story it's just it's all about
what you wanted in life uh-huh
like your friend who's 40 maybe she's
thriving and living her best life and
she doesn't want to be a mother not
every woman wants to be a mother right
okay so we have to stop living by
society means because that is not where
we're at or where this world is evolving
to so it's all what you want if you
wanted to be a dad at 30 i'm sure you
would have been at that at 30. yeah i
almost was
all right but you don't want that for
yourself you know so let her live her
life and do what you want to do i know
she's killing it i know but i'm just
saying like i just don't know if that's
a good look long term that's my opinion
but who are you to judge her i'm not i'm
not just this just
what if you're what if you're married
with kids and unhappy
you know what i mean it's about your
peace of mind and what you want in this
lifetime okay so going back to leo um
it's what he what he wants like that guy
gets a woman thrown at him left and
right you have to understand it's
different than your average guy 100
right clearly at some point
you get tired of this maybe yes and
that's why he trades them out but right
he doesn't want to be a family guy but
he's not looking for love right like
he's just looking for a woman at the
moment everything he's doing is cool
in the moment like jenny said i'm sorry
like amber said
you know
our clock is not ticking like so for me
i have a five year plan i'm 40 i know
i'm gonna i've made it successful in
business and finance i've done my south
beach party days i've done that all
throughout my 20s i've partied enough in
my 20s for 10 lifetime straight up lucky
to be alive over here and then now i
have a plan obviously with valuetainment
everything that i'm doing here with the
show and everything
three-year runway with this kill this
all good by the time i'm 45 have
millions in the bank
ready to start a family no stress in my
life that's my plan i'm not saying
that's beautiful but but you don't even
know if you're going to wake up tomorrow
that's true so like you can have all
this planned or something comes out of
nowhere like if the love of your life
were to walk in this room right now
and
completely sideswipes you oh yeah i'm
i'm a i'm not saying if i met the love
of my life i would say sometimes some
people live on this planet live on this
clock like
you got to live in the moment this is
the only thing that's promised yeah i i
i partially agree with you but there's a
99.9999
chance that everyone listening here is
going to wake up tomorrow so the yolo
thing i think is a little far-fetched
because
unless you're dying of cancer or are
literally one of the people that that
gets hit by a train you're gonna be okay
[Music]